>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, D.C.
>> Mary Louise Kelly:
Hello everybody.
My name is Mary Louise Kelly.
I am the National Security
Correspondent for NPR.
I write spy thrillers
and cover the spy beat.
And I am delighted to be here as
part of the National Book Festival.
And I have been especially
looking forward
to the chance to talk to you.
Please welcome Anne-Marie Slaughter.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> So I will introduce
Anne-Marie as President and CEO.
Of the New America Foundation.
Which is a think-tank
based here in Washington.
However, I suspect that
most people in this room.
Knew you, at least initially,
because of a little
article that you wrote.
Which electrified the country,
I think it's safe to
say, four years ago.
The article was headlined, "Why
Women Still Can't Have It All."
It was the cover of The Atlantic
magazine, in the summer of 2012.
It, overnight, became
the most read article
in the history of that magazine.
And you have since expanded on
it and turned it into a book.
Which is what we are
here to talk about.
Called Unfinished Business.
Congratulations.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Thank you.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: And welcome.
[ Applause ]
So I actually want to
start with that headline.
Because, as I say, I've been looking
forward to this conversation.
And yesterday, I tweeted, why
women still can't have it all.
Looking forward to
putting that question
to Ann-Marie Slaughter
at the book festival.
And you tweeted back.
And you said, we've actually
moved past that question.
And I thought --
[ Laughter ]
-- We have?
How did I miss that?
[ Laughter ]
Let me throw that question
to you first.
Have you figured it all out?
You've cracked this,
and we can have it all?
And you're here to tell us how?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
So, I'm delighted to be
at the National Book Festival.
What is better than a day
entirely devoted to books?
I -- it is -- it's the best.
[ Applause ]
And I love the fact that our
conversation started on Twitter.
And now continues today.
And so what I meant was.
One of the things I've learned
since writing that article.
Is that we really want to move
past the frame of having it all.
And actually, Rebecca Traister
originally wrote a post.
After my article came out.
And taught me things I didn't know.
Which is that having it all
came from Helen Gurley Brown.
The editor of Cosmo.
I think she had a different idea
of what having it all means.
But, more broadly, it
makes women sound selfish.
Right? We're living in
a country where millions
of people are trying to have enough.
To simply get by.
And to pose it as 'can
I have it all?'
Even though you can say that's
part of the American DNA.
I think, starts the whole
conversation off in the wrong place.
So I no longer use the phrase.
I talk about equality
between men and women.
Or gender equality.
And I talk about how can all of us.
And that means men as well as women.
And I am so thrilled to see
so many men in this audience.
How can men and women work?
Live in a way that
they can work and care
for their loved ones
at the same time?
You notice, I also
didn't use balance.
How can we fit those
two things together?
That's the question.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Okay.
And I want to hear some of
your specific thoughts on that.
But before we get ahead
of ourselves.
Let me let you just tell your story.
Of how you came to write that
article and then the book.
You -- I wonder if you can
take us back to that moment?
Where you had finally
gotten the dream job.
You're this high-power position
at the State Department.
And realized it wasn't
working [inaudible].
It wasn't working -- you weren't
able to do the job you needed to do
at home with your family.
What happened?
Tell us where you were and
what was going on in your life.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: So
the first thing you say is yes.
This was absolutely a dream job.
To be the first woman
director of policy planning.
It's the big think-job
in the State Department.
Secretary Clinton wanted
to put a woman in that job.
To show that, you know, we
could do the big thinking too.
And it, you know, I was there
in her early morning meeting.
Every morning, at 8:45.
That's very heady.
And I loved it.
I left my family in Princeton.
There was no way to move my
husband and sons to Washington.
I mean, they were at that point in
middle school and elementary school.
My husband teaches in Princeton.
We would have uprooted them.
My husband would've had to commute.
That was never an option.
In fact, my sons didn't
want me to leave.
But once I said, well, how
about moving to Washington?
It was, "Bye, mom."
You know, it's like, no.
They were not moving.
So I --
>> Mary Louise Kelly: So
you're doing the train commute?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
So I would leave.
I would literally leave the
house at 5 A.M. every morning.
Feeling like kind of
a thief in the night.
All three -- got boys are sleeping.
My husband and my sons.
And I would come down here.
Make it in time for
the early meeting.
And go back late on Friday.
So it meant I had two days a week.
And, I mean, look.
People, many people don't
see their families enough.
But it was, it was hard.
But it was doable.
My husband stepped up
and was the lead parent.
And then, as I wrote,
my elder son was,
I think, a not unusual teenager.
I mean, it's not that he --
>> Mary Louise Kelly:
Which is to say, what?
A complete nightmare at [inaudible]?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
More or less.
Yeah.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Having
a new teenager in our house.
I'll back that up.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yeah,
so then he turned into, you know.
Kind of, you come downstairs
and say "Good morning."
And he'd take your head off.
And you'd say, "Excuse
me for living."
And he would -- but he
was making bad choices.
And indeed, you know,
I didn't expect that.
He was with the wrong crowd.
Many parents know this.
He was tuning out at school.
He started getting into
trouble with the local police.
Little stuff.
But enough that, you
know, I'd get a call.
And Andy would say, you
know, "He's been suspended."
And I'd be, "Suspended?"
You know, it was -- I
was not prepared for it.
And it got to the point
that I was literally asking.
What am I doing here?
You know, why am I here?
When my son so clearly
needs me and his father.
It wasn't like I was
going to go save the day.
It was, we needed both
hands on deck.
And that really just starting
to change the way I'd
always thought about this.
I had always said to younger women.
Of course you can do it.
You just have to want
to want it enough.
And I believed that.
And I knew I had a
lot of advantages.
A flexible job and money.
I knew that.
But I still really
thought, you can do it.
And when this happened, I
suddenly realized, wait a minute.
All these other women
who had a divorce.
Or a child with special needs.
Or had to move.
Or don't have the advantages I do.
It's not that they want to drop out.
They're simply choosing
the people they love.
Over the work they may equally love.
But that's something we
should admire and celebrate.
Not accuse them of having
failed some, you know, idea.
That they're supposed
to be able to do it all.
And the other thing was.
There's a huge number of things
we could do in our society.
To make it a lot easier
for women, as well as men.
So that's why I wrote the article.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: So let me walk
you through some of the strategies.
Because I think we're all
sitting here thinking.
Okay, so how do we --
it's not have it all.
That's not the way we
should be framing the goal.
How do we -- how do we try
to have the work we love?
And take care of the family
that we love at the same time?
One of the things that intrigued me.
That you propose, is
interval training.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yeah.
>> Mary Louise Kelly:
Explain what you mean by that.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
So in the book --
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Because
I'm visioning a treadmill.
And that's just not what it is.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: So one of
the core reasons this is so hard.
Is that we still have a 1950s
idea of what a career looks like.
You come out of school.
You plunge into your career.
You start climbing this ladder.
In your 30s and 40s, or
in my case, 40s and 50s.
When you are having children.
When, typically, when most
of us are having children.
That's right at the heart of
the hard part of the ladder.
And you're soaring up,
and you reach your peak.
Sometime in your 50s
or your early 60s.
You retire at 65, and you die at 75.
That isn't our lives.
That's just not our lives.
Girls today have a
life expectancy of 86.
Which means a large number of
people are expected to live to 100.
And you can read plenty of things
on the cover of TIME magazine.
That says we're going
to live to 120.
And I don't know what
we're going to do then.
But there's plenty of time.
If Hillary Clinton wins, she'll
be 70 when she becomes president.
And she didn't start
her political career
until after Chelsea went to college.
You know, she was a lawyer
and she did lots of things.
But she started --
she ran for Senate.
She ran for president.
She became secretary of state.
She ran for president again.
All after her daughter
went to college.
So interval training
is the idea that all
of us would think about our careers.
As periods where we go hard.
Come out of school.
You're young.
When I was young, I pulled
plenty of all-nighters.
You know, I could travel.
I could do all that.
I didn't have a house or a husband.
Or, you know, I was free.
You go hard and then you slow down.
This is how athletes get
into peak performance.
Training, right?
You think about on a Stairmaster.
You go hard and you slow down.
And women and men should be
able to think of their careers.
In terms of multiple intervals.
So that they're going
to work longer.
But they're also going to have
time for the people they love.
Because your kids are
only young once.
And your parents are only
aging and needing you, once.
Or a spouse who is ill.
Or anybody else in your family.
And in -- really, there's no
reason there isn't time for both.
Except for we have this
very artificial idea
of how you have to work.
>> Mary Louise Kelly:
So where are you
in your interval training right now?
Because I have to pause and note.
You decided to leave
the high-powered job
at the State Department.
And kind of, you know,
downshift, let's call it.
Leaning out, whatever
you want to call it.
And I have to know that
your version of leaning out.
Involves being a tenured
Princeton professor.
Writing a best-selling, New
York Times, best-seller book.
Founding a think-tank
here in Washington.
And you've got another book
coming out in the spring.
So if that is leaning
out, count me in.
[ Laughter ]
Where are you now?
What's -- I mean, how's your
family doing now, if I can ask?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: So, I mean,
one of the great ironies, of course.
Is I write this article about
wanting to be home with my children.
It exploded.
And suddenly, I had more invitations
than I knew what to do with.
And I was spending less
time with my children.
And every now and again,
one of my sons will grumble.
I'm going to write an
Atlantic article.
And I'm going to tell you
what it was really like.
That mom was never home.
So I am very high-energy.
No question.
And yes. So what -- but
here's the difference.
I still work a lot.
I love my work.
But there's a huge difference
between what I'm doing.
And taking that really big job.
One more step up in
the State Department.
I would have been an undersecretary
or a deputy secretary.
One more step up as a
professor, or I'd been a dean.
I'd be a president of a University.
Those jobs, your time
is not your own.
You cannot say, it's
my son's birthday.
It's a period of vacation.
Whatever it is.
What I'm doing, I'm
running an organization.
But it's 200 people,
and I'm the boss.
So I can be here two days a week.
But then be home at other times.
I can adjust.
When I needed to take my son to
look at colleges, we could do that.
So I do hope that there is another
really big job in my future.
But it will be after both
sons have left the house.
And so what I've done is to choose
the kinds of work I want to do.
To create a lot of flexibility.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: So talk to
us about a phrase you just used.
The phrase lead parent.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yes.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: You and I
have talked about that before.
And when I mention that, I'm
always interested to see.
It's men who seem to
really relate to that.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yes.
>> Mary Louise Kelly:
Because it seems
to invite a bigger,
more creative vision.
Of how a family can work.
And speak to this idea
of interval training.
And one of you is lead parenting.
While the other one goes
out and does something.
And --
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
That's right.
>> Mary Louise Kelly:
-- Then you flip it.
Is that the way it's worked for you?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
I was going to say yes.
And then I'm thinking, my
husband would say, yeah, my turn.
My turn's next.
So I thought really
hard about lead parent.
And talked about it with my husband.
And you're absolutely right.
It is chosen, in part,
because stay-at-home dad.
Is not a status that
most men aspire to.
It is -- and I don't like
stay-at-home mom either.
It implies, you know,
you're a professional.
You're in the office.
And if you're not, if you're
parenting, you're staying at home.
I -- lead parenting is what
my husband's been doing.
That means parenting is hard.
It involves all sorts of things.
He's taking the lead.
He's the one who's there.
He's the one who may call
for all sorts of things.
I'm still actively a parent.
But when somebody's got to
be there, it's my husband.
And yes, I imagine that men
and women can be lead
parents, and trade off.
And the men who are lead parents.
The reward is they get that special
relationship with their kids.
That women have traditionally had.
And most of us don't
want to give up.
And they can work too.
So it is a very deliberate
construction
of parenting or caregiving.
You could say, I'm the lead
caregiver for my own parent.
In a way that makes
it equally important.
And not this residual, oh,
I'm just the person at home.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: I
mean, it sounds like some
of the point you're making.
Is it matters what we call things.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yes.
It does.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: A lead
parent who happens to be male.
Is the same thing as a
stay-at-home dad, but --
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: It matters.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: -- It
matters what words we use
when we talk about it.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
Well, we used to --
I lived through changing
Mrs. and Miss,
to Ms. And when that
first was proposed.
It was like, oh, you've
got to be kidding.
M S, Ms.. Although I
was from the south.
So Ms. was pretty common.
But that made a huge difference.
Because before, the thing
you knew about a female.
Was, was she married or not.
And that was sending the signal
that that was the most important
thing to know about her.
Was she Ms. or Mrs.?
So it does matter how
we talk about things.
We talk about same-sex marriage.
We talk -- we reframe these issues.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Okay,
so here is my confession.
Your publisher was kind enough
to courier your book to me.
At my hotel room, where I was
in New York, on a work trip.
So that I could read it
before I interviewed you.
And I was trying to read it
on the train, on the way home.
And the soccer carpool of
one of my kids fell apart.
And I'm trying and fielding
these frantic phone calls.
From a stranded child
on the soccer field.
In the quiet car.
So we sort that out.
[ Laughter ]
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
We've all been there.
>> Mary Louise Kelly:
I'm trying to read it
in between doing interviews
for my day job.
And my other son fractured
his ankle.
And we end up in the
emergency pediatrician visit.
Etcetera, etcetera.
Long story short, I end
up frantically reading the
last chapters in the taxi.
On the way to interview you.
[ Laughter ]
Which prompts me to wonder.
Are the people who would
benefit from reading your book?
And some of the ideas in it,
too frazzled to find
the time to read it?
[ Laughter ]
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Well, I
have heard from a number of people.
That their mother gave
them the book.
In other words, the person
that had the time to read.
And my mother often now reads
things I don't have time to read.
And lets me know about them.
So I do think, yes, the people
who are in the midst of this.
Either mothers or fathers, maybe
can read it chapter by chapter.
And I did have people even
with my Atlantic article.
Telling me, it's 13,000 words.
You can't be a working mother.
Because you know we don't
have time to read that.
I -- you know, what
I would just say is.
I read first thing,
late, last at night.
Always. And I actually
start every day.
And I will wake up
earlier to do this.
I read for 20 minutes
with my cup of coffee.
Because that's --
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Just
pleasure, or catching up on --
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Pleasure.
Pleasure. No, no, no.
Only pleasure.
It can fiction or nonfiction.
I generally read fiction at night,
and nonfiction in the morning.
Because my brain is
fresher in the morning.
But it's just this little island.
Of that cup of coffee and my book.
A lot of people meditate.
I think about books when I meditate.
So it's just -- and so I think
you can make time to read.
But I agree, I've -- we've all
been to where you described.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: So
you mentioned your boss
at State Department
was Hillary Clinton.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yep.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: A few of her
emails have been making their way
into the public domain lately.
And your name comes
up in some of them.
And I want to ask about one, in
particular, that caught my eye.
This was an email that you wrote
around Christmastime, 2009.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yep.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: And
you wrote to Hillary Clinton,
begging her to take a day off.
What prompted that?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
I just have to say,
before I answer this question.
When that email came out and
people started calling me about it.
I thought, I can't believe this.
I wrote her hundreds of emails.
About things like Middle East
peace, and Syria and China.
And all anybody wants to know about.
Is my asking her to take time off.
So even there, it was
kind of a reframing
of what I've been known for.
So that was -- what I actually said.
Was, there I was, we're all working.
My husband kind of
believes in Santa Claus.
Which is to say that Christmas
magically appears every year.
I mean, he is -- he's wonderful.
But stockings, and he cooks.
But somebody else organizes
the meal.
So what I was -- I
wrote her, and said.
Would you leave on the 22nd?
Because if you leave on
the 22nd, we can all leave.
And then a lot of people are
going to be, need to be home.
I needed to be home to
make Christmas happen.
And so I wrote her that.
And she did.
And I knew, because that's
the kind of person she is.
That if I framed it that way.
If I said, take a day off because
you've been working too hard.
No. If I said, leave two days early,
so everybody else can
have the holiday.
She would respond.
And she did.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: And she did?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
And she did.
She left and absolutely anybody.
Anybody in Washington knows,
if the principle is there.
Nobody else leaves.
Right? You have to
-- and so she did.
And then all the rest of us
felt like we could take the day.
You know, vacation
days to go home early.
And she did.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Did you
watch her struggle with the juggle?
The work-life balance?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: No.
Because, again, I mean
she's at that stage of life.
Where her family is her
foundation and support.
Rather than her, you know,
needing to attend to them.
So she did go home
almost every weekend.
To be with Bill Clinton.
And she would come home, come
back, refreshed on Sundays.
You rarely saw her
on the Sunday shows.
Only occasionally.
She really would go home.
And it was clear.
I always tell this story.
That before Chelsea got
married, we were in Beijing.
And she was being interviewed
as U.S. Secretary of State.
By some Chinese TV interviewer.
And right at the end
of the interview.
He said to her, "Well, what
about Chelsea's wedding?"
And she said, with just right
off the top of her head.
She said, "Oh, well,
that's my real life.
" And I thought, yeah.
That's the way I feel too.
That's my real life.
And so, you know, her
family, Chelsea
and her husband, were
hugely important.
But they were supports, not drains.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: But I want to
stay with this idea of, you know.
You're in this high-power
job at the State Department.
And you're thinking
about, oh, my gosh.
Who's going to put the Christmas
lights on the Christmas tree?
Because I -- you know.
And for so many of us who've
struggled, trying to figure out.
Even, I guess my point is,
I mean, you do knowledge.
You're writing from a
privileged position.
And that, for a lot of people.
The struggle isn't,
can you have it all?
It's like, can you have enough
to get dinner on the table?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yes.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: And pay the
electric bill to keep the lights on.
But that someone with your
resources and your position.
You're still struggling
with the fact
that there are only
24 hours in the day.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yes.
So a couple things.
Yes, absolutely.
So first of all, I'm
really easy on myself.
As a -- in the sense that we just
knew we were going to drop balls.
We told our sons early on.
Like, we are not going to
remember to get this form in.
We are not going to
be the class parents.
We're just not.
And I figured that parenting
them the way we, best we could.
With a lot of love.
And was going to be more important.
Than a lot of activities I
might otherwise have done.
And the other thing.
And this is, I write about
this at length, in this book.
As the woman, you do have to let go.
Right? My husband was
willing to be lead parent.
But at some point, he said to me.
"I'm doing this.
But I'm doing this my way.
You are not micromanaging
how I parent.
If you want to do that,
you come home."
Right? And he does things
very differently than I do.
I always say, you know,
I'd come home and want them
to clean their rooms and all this.
And he would spend the weekend
showing them all the Marx
Brothers movies.
Like --
[ Laughter ]
-- And I came to realize, you know,
you really, you do have to assume.
That a man is as capable
at home, and as a parent.
As you are in the office.
He is going to do it
differently, often.
And, you know, everybody's
personalities differ.
Sometimes the man is the neat
nick, and the woman isn't.
I mean, it's not -- there
are many differences.
But in the office, even though I do
something differently than a man.
I assume I know what I'm doing.
And I had to come to accept that
although I thought I knew better.
Because my mother raised me.
And her mother raised her.
Who is to say I knew better?
And he certainly thinks
he knows what he's doing.
And I had to let go.
And so that -- and
balls got dropped.
Things that I thought needed
to be done were not done.
But things that he thought
were important did get done.
And as I look at our sons now.
I think probably knowing
the Marx Brothers movies.
Is more important than
whatever it was.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Than
whether their beds were made.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
Yeah, exactly.
Their beds aren't made.
I can promise you that.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: As you've
talked to people about this.
And been on book tour.
Do you find that men
are as interested
in this conversation as women are?
I mean, it will not escape
anyone's notice that we're two women
up here, talking about it.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yes, yes.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: I
do notice, like you did,
the number of men in the audience.
Which is great.
But is it a different conversation
when you find yourself
fielding questions from men?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
So I've never been
in an audience only of men.
That would be great, actually.
I have been in a growing number of
audiences that are almost 50-50.
And they are student audiences.
Because young people,
like in business school
or law school, or university.
Couples come.
And they're assuming that they're
going to both have to do this.
And, you know, I write about
questions and conversations.
You need to have with each other.
To make sure that's
going to be a real thing.
And not just a paper thing.
Because most of my friends
thought it was to be equal too.
And then, when the
guy got a promotion.
And it never occurred to
him, he wouldn't take it.
And then she couldn't
take her promotion.
Because they could both do it.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Like what?
What are some of the
questions we should be asking?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
That's the key one.
Is if, you know, we
support each other's career.
Will you move for me?
Right? If I get a fabulous
job somewhere else.
Will you move?
Will you leave your job, so I
can take this great opportunity?
Or will you defer your
promotion so I can take mine?
That is not generally part
of what most men expect.
But to your original question.
I think this generation of
men want a number of things.
I think they want a closer
relationship with their kids.
Than many of them had
with their fathers.
Just like I wanted to work
in a way my mother didn't.
Many men think, why shouldn't I
have that bond with my children?
And why shouldn't I have
that side of my life too?
And lots of men I know
think it's crazy
that women get maternity leave.
And they get a week.
Right? That's not fair.
Right? That means a mother will
bond more closely with the child.
Not because she's a woman.
But because she's the
one who's, you know,
feeding and diapering the child.
And so if a man does that.
And we have all the same-sex
couples and single fathers.
Of course men can do that.
So I do think -- I
think of my generation.
And certainly my father's
generation, no.
This is a female conversation.
But I think for the younger
generation, it's both.
But again, we have to
assume when men talk about.
What they're doing
with their children.
It's probably a different
conversation in many ways.
And that's normal.
>> Mary Louise Kelly:
Let me ask you about some
of the nitty-gritty details.
As we talk about this stuff.
I noticed you were tweeting
this week about a house bill.
That would require
baby changing stations.
In men's and women's room
in federal buildings.
And putting aside the question
of whether we will even have
separate men's and women's rooms.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
Yes, exactly.
>> Mary Louise Kelly:
Five years from now.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yep.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: I
noticed here, we don't.
Unisex. But this should be
as much a men's challenge,
problem, as women's.
And I wondered when I
read that, you know.
Whether you've been on this path.
It's great to think the big
strategic policy thoughts.
But you've also got to
get the details right.
To make any of this work for us.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yep, yep.
Yes. And I -- you know,
somebody tweeted that at me.
And I thought, yes.
That's a classic example
of reinforcing stereotypes.
Right? Because we are assuming
that men don't change diapers.
That's assuming that women do.
That's assuming that
women are the caregivers
and men are the breadwinners.
And that's exactly
what we have to undo.
So something as small as that.
And is like the way we talk.
Is very important.
But also, if you are
a single father.
What -- where are you
supposed to change your child?
Or not a single father.
You're just a father who
is with their children.
What are you supposed to do?
I mean, you ought to be able to
have a surface to change your baby.
Just as much as a mother does.
So those little things do matter.
And they change our assumptions.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: I want to
open it up to questions in a moment.
But let me throw one more at you.
Which is, I have to ask.
We've been talking
about Hillary Clinton.
Your name keeps appearing on lists
of possible cabinet secretaries.
Should there be a President Clinton.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
Unprompted by me, I should add.
But --
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Unsolicited.
But, I mean, where are you
in your personal journey?
If I can call it that.
Would -- if the right
phone call were to come.
Are you at a point where you would
lean back into a big Washington job?
Where you don't have control over,
you know, it's my kids birthday.
And I need to go.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
So, ideally, not quite yet.
I mean, ideally, I'm very
committed to new American.
I still have a son at home.
Although not for that much longer.
Oh, well, I say that.
We are applying to college.
So I'm going to assume
not for that much longer.
You know, there are things that,
if the president asks you to do.
And probably, for me particularly,
if she's the first woman president.
You say yes.
But I can say, I'm very committed.
I promised the Board of New America
that I would be there
for five years.
And I'm very committed
to building it.
I certainly would hope to be there
by the end of her administration.
But not necessarily
at the beginning.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: All right.
Let me open it up to your questions.
I think we have microphones here.
And forgive me.
If you can line up at the mics.
And we'll just go back and forth.
If you care to identify
yourself, that would be great.
Ask a question.
And if you can keep it short.
So we can get to as
many of you as possible.
That would be great.
Let me start with this
lady right here.
Please, go ahead.
>> Oh, okay.
I could tell where
you were pointing.
I'm Sister Marge Clark.
And I work with Network, which
is a national Catholic social
justice lobby.
I'm very excited.
I didn't -- I was excited,
looking at the title of your book.
One of the things I
work on is legislation.
To improve women's
places in the workplace.
And there are some really
good bills out right now.
And I was interested in
hearing what you said.
About the changing table
in men's rooms and things.
I wonder, are you putting
your name and your power?
Behind some of these other
bills that are out there?
In terms of things like
pregnancy adaptations.
The things like paid
leave and sick leave.
All really affect women
more than men.
But they affect both.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yes.
>> And I'm just wondering, are you
able to put your power behind that?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yes.
Yes, and I'm glad you asked.
Because, again, so the message
of the book is kind of twofold.
That the unfinished business of the
women's movement is to value care.
As much as we value competition.
So traditional women's work, as
much as traditional men's work.
And then to expect men and
women to do it equally.
So valuing care is, there's
an entire legislative agenda.
And we are seeing it
in this administrate --
in this election year.
And it's important that we are.
And we're seeing it from
Republicans and Democrats.
I think of it as the care
agenda, not the women's agenda.
Again, because I want to
undo these stereotypes.
But it's the big three.
It's paid family leave.
It should -- we should just --
this is one place where we could
leapfrog the rest of the world.
And get beyond maternity
leave, paternity leave.
Leave to take care of elders.
Just call it family leave.
And make it available to everyone.
Regardless of whom
they're caring for.
So paid family leave is essential.
And New America is working
hard on paid family leave.
Then, affordable, quality childcare.
I'd say childcare and eldercare.
But let's start with childcare.
Because the cost of
childcare for two children.
Is more expensive than the
cost of rent in all 50 states.
And that's driving people
out of the workforce.
So childcare is essential.
And again, you're seeing,
Secretary Clinton has an important
proposal there.
And then finally, real,
flexible work.
Right? Not just, you
know, a day here or there.
But the ability to work remotely.
Or to come in late.
Or to leave early.
A whole set of policies
that other countries.
At least our peer countries, have.
And we can also encourage.
So --
>> Mary Louise Kelly: And that's
something you think should be
federally mandated?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Well,
I -- so there are things like.
There are things like,
you can mandate not
discriminating against people.
On the basis of part-time
work or flexible work.
That one is harder to legislate.
But there are ways that
you can encourage it.
And provide incentives.
And the first two.
On paid family leave, I
think business is going
to want federal standards.
Because right now,
we have four states.
Including New York and California.
So two huge states that
have paid family leave.
And a bunch of cities.
That means you're going to
have a patchwork, right?
It's going to be very unpredictable,
which city or state you're in.
And gradually, then, business
would prefer one uniform standard.
So that one, definitely.
Childcare, you know,
President Nixon vetoed a bill.
That had been passed by
both houses of Congress.
For universal childcare, in 1971.
It'd be great to get back there.
But I'd settle for
lots of incentives.
And other things that
encourage both on-site childcare
and community care.
>> Mary Louise Kelly:
Okay, thank you.
Question right here.
>> Thank you.
My question is going to be about
transition in interval training.
And my context is, I'm a
military family member.
So my husband is active duty.
He deployed, I ramp it up.
I am also in the military,
as a reservist.
And I have a civilian career.
My turn to deploy is coming.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yeah.
>> So how, when you're
not changing jobs?
But you are going to
have different abilities.
In how much time you can devote
to that, and not everything else.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Yep.
>> Can you tell us, what have
your best practices been?
As you've gone through
some of those intervals?
How did you transition?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Absolutely.
So thank you.
And first of all, I should just say.
When I did feel like I
wasn't ever seeing my family.
And this was hard.
I would think to myself, you know.
Our military deploy
for a year at a time.
And I'm seeing my children
every sixth day.
They're seeing -- they're not
seeing their family for a year.
So I want to start by thanking you.
For your service and
your husband's service.
[ Applause ]
To your question, this
is really important.
I mean, what we really
do need to do.
Is change employer attitudes.
So that when they see,
you know, a part-time job.
Even no job for a while.
They don't think, oh, I'm not
going to hire this person.
I'm going to hire the person that
has that sterling 1950s resume.
Where it just goes straight up.
That's the most important
thing we can do.
But beyond that, you do
need -- I say in the book.
Don't drop out, defer.
Right? So defer the big job.
But keep your skills in.
Keep your contacts ready.
Think about things that, you know,
let's say you need
to learn fundraising.
Or you need to learn
public speaking.
Or having something written
with your name on it.
Would help your career
down the line.
Use that time to do those things.
That's also a better story.
So you can say, yes, you know.
It was my turn to be lead parent.
During that time, I wrote this.
Or I took on a new set of
experiences through volunteering.
That, I say, think about
your career as a portfolio
of skills and experiences.
And figure out where you can add,
even as you're being lead parent.
>> Mary Louise Kelly:
That's great advice.
Question here.
>> Hi, I'm Phil.
I'm a generic guy.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Welcome.
>> You're clearly very successful.
And you talk about success,
and success is good.
I think we all want
to be successful.
But I think a big part of
work-life balance is failure.
It's dealing with your inability to
work as hard as you want at work.
Make a project go.
Being absent from your kids
soccer game, etcetera, etcetera.
Can you tell us about
a time when you failed?
Seriously failed.
Maybe a time when you and your
husband came close to divorce.
Because you couldn't
balance your life and work.
So that we have some perspective
on what it's really like.
To really struggle.
Thank you.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Okay.
So I will thank you
for the question.
It's an important one.
And I will say two things.
So one, and I wrote about this.
When my son was in first
grade -- my elder son.
He was asked to draw his family.
And he drew me as a laptop.
[ Laughter ]
Not a person typing at a laptop.
There was no person in the picture.
There was just a laptop.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Ow!
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
That was not a good moment.
Right? That he drew
his father cooking.
Right? His father was
there, I wasn't.
I was just become Dean of
the Woodrow Wilson School.
And clearly, I was absent.
So that was not a good moment.
And yes, I could write an entire
book on inter-spousal negotiation.
Most of our conversation
consisted of.
You didn't give me credit for this.
I did this, you did this.
We tried every system
under the sun to divide it.
You know, hours on
the refrigerators.
Computer apps, you name it.
Because we were constantly
pulling and tugging.
And, you know, there are
those games we missed.
And I don't think my elder son spun
out because I went to Washington.
But I don't think it helped.
I think he was trying
really hard to be mature.
He was 12.
He knew this was an
important job for me.
But he had also just
started middle school.
And I think he felt abandoned.
And knew he couldn't express that.
So no question.
And I'll just conclude that
by saying, at one point.
My husband and I had
been having a discussion.
That you might call a fight,
if you were so inclined.
And my older son came in and
said -- this was a while back.
And he said, you know, "Mom.
Are you and dad going to
divorce when we go to college?"
And I said, "Sweetheart,
when you go to college.
We won't have anything
to fight about."
[ Laughter ]
And that's true.
So, absolutely.
But we are -- I mean, all of us.
This is hard.
That's part of my point.
It is hard.
And if you have anything else.
Again, a job away, a child
with special needs, a divorce.
Anything else can tip that.
So then I talk about it in the book.
The tipping point, where suddenly,
you just can't do it anymore.
And you've got to change jobs.
Or you have to, you
know, somehow adjust.
So that you can respond to
the needs of the moment.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Thank you.
Question here.
Yes, sir.
>> I'm wondering what
advice you would give?
Or what you would say to
a single, working mom.
Who's going to be vacuuming
this room tonight.
Or who's working in security
for this building right now.
Or who's signing up at front.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: So I
would say, that in my article.
I had nothing to say to her.
Because I wrote that
article from the position
of privilege that I was in.
I knew it.
I was writing for The Atlantic.
So I knew what my readership
looked like.
But I would say, I also
thought about gender issues.
Almost entirely in terms of the fact
there were too few women at the top.
And that what we needed to do
was to get more women at the top.
Four years later.
After three years reading,
writing, wrestling with issues.
I think, yep, there are
too few women at the top.
And there are too many
at the bottom.
The poorest people in our society.
The poorest people are
those single mothers.
And two-thirds of minimum
wage workers, shift workers,
and part-time workers, are women.
So the reason I focus on care.
Is because I think the -- I buy
my way out of care problems.
That mother you're
describing, can't.
And so things like
paid family leave.
She can lose her job
when her child is sick.
That's -- a society that
says you have to choose.
Between staying home with
the child, and your job.
Is an immoral society.
So I'm focused on those issues.
[ Applause ]
So thanks for the question.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: Thank you.
Right here.
>> Hi. My name is Caroline.
I graduated from college
two years ago.
And I was interested
in what you said
about the few years
right after you graduate.
Those being really important years
to just totally be
all in on your career.
And what I have found with my
friends, since we graduated.
And since we lost this incredible
community that we had at school.
People really clung
to relationships.
My friends really clung to
boyfriends, or guys they'd just met.
Or partners they'd just met.
Because they missed that
feeling of community.
And my question for
you is, you know.
As we think about how much we
want to value our relationships.
This early on in our career.
What's your advice?
Do you think that it is
crucial to have those years?
Where you don't think about a
relationship at all, this early?
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: That --
I don't think I've ever
been asked that question.
And it's an important one.
I mean, after I wrote my article.
A young Princeton graduate
wrote to me.
And said she was going
to leave her job
to follow her boyfriend
across the country.
And that everybody was disapproving.
And she said, ironically,
had she been leaving her job
to follow her girlfriend
across the country.
Probably, it would have been better.
But her larger point
was, wait just a minute.
Why is it that Princeton
teaches me I should follow my
career everywhere?
And not invest in relationships?
And I would say, again, that's
been part of my journey.
The theme of this entire
book festival is journeys.
And I would say, I now think that
investing in those relationships.
And I think that is the
work of a lead parent.
My mother was a homemaker,
was investing in her family.
Is critically important.
Because that -- I do think, you
know, you could work harder.
You can travel.
Absolutely.
But I do think those
relationships are your foundation.
Right? When things go wrong,
that's what catches you.
Whether it's your family,
or it's your best friends.
And family is anything,
people you love.
Whom you chose to make your family.
So I do think that's important.
I think it's -- I would say
it's a time when you can spend.
More time on your work
than your relationships.
But I would say you
shouldn't ever do only one.
To the exclusion of the other.
If you possibly can.
>> Mary Louise Kelly:
But to the specific point
about how important
it is in your 20s.
You know, a year out of college.
To ramp up --
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter:
To go for it.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: --
Fast, and just go for it.
I mean, you do write about how much
easier it has made your choices
and path.
That you got to a pretty
successful point in your career.
Relatively early on.
So that you were the boss.
And you could set the
agenda and the schedule.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: I do.
But I also -- I was divorced at 30.
And married again at 35.
And I got tenure in between.
And I sometimes wonder, what
if I hadn't been divorced?
What if we were having
children in our early 30s?
And I've also written about my
infertility problems, right?
I waited until I was 35.
And I had a child at 38.
And that was a terrible period.
Where I really thought, I
have sacrificed my ability.
To have biological
children, to my career.
And so part of what I'm
saying now is, that's right.
I mean, if you ask me -- if you
come to me as a young woman.
Given the world we're in.
I'm realistic enough to say,
hey, try to make partner first.
Try to get to a place first.
But I'll also say, try to
do that by your early 30s.
Not your late 30s.
But what I'm saying in this book
is, it doesn't have to be that way.
Right? We should be able to
say, you've gotten up to here.
On whatever path you're on.
You now slow down.
You don't drop out.
You slow down.
You have your children.
You do whatever.
And then, when you're ready.
Your workplace ought to say, great.
You're ready.
Let's see if you can do the job.
But yes, given where we are.
It is a good idea to get as high
as you can, as early as you can.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: All right.
I'm going to take one last one.
If you can keep it quick.
Right here.
>> Sure. You talked a little
bit about this in the talk.
But I'd like to hear
a little bit more.
What effect do you believe a
continued prevalence and acceptance?
Of children raised by
same-sex couples will have?
On accelerating the decoupling
and dismantling of gender-biases.
Related to how we align
caregiving in our careers?
Both in terms of public
policy and corporate practice.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: I'm so
glad you asked that question.
I think same-sex couples
are leading the way.
And indeed, it was early on, when
I was giving a talk on my article.
When a young woman
came up to me and said.
You know, I and my partner
-- it was another woman.
She said, there is
no default role here.
There is no, I'm the
woman, so I'm the caregiver.
And she's the woman, so
she's the breadwinner.
And ditto for two men.
There is no default.
And so what I argue, is we should
all think about it that way.
It depends on your
personality, your ambitions.
Your level of income, your boss.
Where you are in life.
All of those things
should determine.
Who's lead parent and
who's lead breadwinner.
And it doesn't always
have to be, you know,
lead one and lead the other.
There are times you can
really divide it equally.
But those are the factors
that matter.
Not whatever genitalia
you were born with.
>> Mary Louise Kelly: I don't think
we can top that as an end place.
So we will leave it there.
Thank you, Anne-Marie
Slaughter, thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
>> Anne-Marie Slaughter: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.